la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion de la motion de
censure déposée en application de
l'article 49 aléa 3 de la Constitution
par Madame Mathilde Panau madame cyielle
châelin monsieur André chassen monsieur
Boris Vallot et 145 membres de
l'Assemblée nationale la première
ministre ayant engagé la responsabilité
du Gouvernement sur l'adoption en
lecture définitive du projet de loi de
finance pour
2024 alors je vais passer la parole à
Monsieur le Président CoCr
pour la France insouise pour une durée
de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes président n'a jamais été
sanctionné la présidente monsieur le
Président
ah je sais mais je vais vous répondre
je vais donc pouvoir
commencer madame la Première ministre
chers collègues madame la Première
ministre nous voici rendu à la dernière
motion de censure de votre budget mais
aussi de l'année 2023 elle a donc
vocation à censurer l'ensemble de votre
œuvre si j'ose dire et plus globalement
ce qu'est ou c'est que ce que peut-être
est devenu le macronisme au fond ce qui
est votre raison d'être c'est
d'appliquer coûte que coûte une
politique néolibérale minoritaire dans
le pays par la seule force du 493
l'assemblée et de la répression sociale
en dehors cela a été vrai pour le budget
comme pour la réforme des retraites pour
imposer cette politique qui en dernière
instance vous amène à toujours avantager
les revenus du capital sur ceux du
travail vous n'hésitez pas à piétiner la
démocratie parlementaire et emprunter
des voies toujours plus autoritaires
pire désormais pour vous donner un peu
d'air vous emprunterz à l'extrême droite
sa fonction historique qui est de
diviser le peuple les plus défavoris
entre eux en leur faisant croire que
leur sort et leur intérêt commun n'est
plus que confrontation et concurrence
quand on les définit par leur
nationalité non content de jeter en
pâure l'étranger comme l'origine tous
les mots de notre pays à partir des
fantasmes rang de l'extrême droite vous
bâtissez désormais des majorités sur ces
idées des majorités tout courts
d'ailleurs puisque un simple calcul
permet de constater que votre
ignominieuse loi sur l'immigration ne
serait jamais passé si le rassemblement
national avait choisi de s'y opposer
oui madame la Première ministre vousouz
votre gouvernement mériter d'être
censuré pour ce budget qui n'a obtenu
aucune majorité ou plutôt si contre lui
puisque lors de la seule occasion de
voter qui nous a été donnée il a été
battu dans la commission que j'ai
l'honneur de présider ce budget
n'atteindra pas les objectifs fixés mais
surtout ne répondra pas au besoins du
pays en effet les signes d'une
dégradation de l'activité économique
sont là sur le 3è trimestre de 2023 le
PIB s'est révélé en légère récession et
le pouvoir d'achat se replie les
dernières prévisions de croissance ou à
0,8 % s'éloigne même de l'objectif de 1
% dont vous vous ventiez déjà il y a
quelques mois le choc de la remontée des
taux se diffuse désormais dans
l'ensemble de l'économie alors que selon
les données de la Banque de France les
entreprises françaises sont endettées à
78,4 % du PIB soit un niveau très
supérieur au 57,4 % de moyenne de la
zone euro par ailleurs le nombre
d'entreprises créer ralenti fortement
les défaillances flambent le secteur de
la construction souffre et les carnets
de commande se réduisent dans
l'industrie du côté des ménages le
constat n'est pas différent puisqu'ils
investissent moins ces données annoncent
une année 2024 dégradé l'OCDE a abaissé
fortement sa prévision de croissance la
dégradant de 1,2 % à 0,8 %. l'OFCE
anticipe le REC un recul de
l'investissement des entreprise de - 1,1
% et le chômage passerait de 7,4 % à la
fin 2023 C 7,9 % à la fin 2024 bien
éloigné de ce plein emploi que le chef
de l'État a encore présenté hier comme
un fait accompli si j'en crois les
propos du ministre de l'économie et des
finances la solution serait alors
d'imposer des baisses de dépenses
publiques supplémentaires et de
s'attaquer une fois de plus aux salariés
le genre de remède des médecins de
Molière qui accentue le mal en
affaiblissant la consommation populaire
lorsqu'il y a risque de récession le
temps n'est pas au coupe budgétaire mais
à un interventionnisme renforcé
la Commission européenne constate
elle-même que les politiques
austéritaires prévues auront un effet
restrictif sur l'activité en 2024 voilà
une raison supplémentaire pour préserver
dans les mois à venir une flexibilité
budgétaire suffisante afin de faire face
à ce climat défavorable ce n'est donc
pas la réduction des dépenses qui
permettra d'améliorer la situation
économique et sociale du pays en
particulier lorsque des rapport comme
celui de l'ADEM publié ce mois-ci
soulligne que le coût de l'inaction
climatique serait plus de quatre fois
super aux efforts financiers nécessaires
à la bifurcation
écologique avec ce budget le
gouvernement persiste dans son erreur et
nous fait perdre un temps précieux
irrattrapable dans la course de vitesse
contre le réchauffement climatique le
constat que je viens de vous exposer est
manifestement partagé en partie au sein
de cet hémicycle lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 une
majorité en faveur d'une plus grande
justice fiscale s'est dessiné en
proposant notamment un afflux de
recettes il y a des amendements taxant
la part des profits utilisés uniquement
pour nourrir la rente capitaliste vous
les avez tous effacés parce que vous
refuser de prendre un ctime au capital
quand dans le même temps vous rabotez
les indemnités des chômeurs oui madame
la Première ministre vous et votre
gouvernement méritaz d'être censuré pour
la méthode utilisée ce ne sont plus
seulement les votes dont vous privez
l'Assemblée nationale mais de tout débat
dans
l'hémicycle quel pire message envoyé aux
Français que de décréter ainsi inutilité
de leurs représentants juste parce que
la composition de l'Assemblée ne vous a
jamais satisfait et que le pire de la 5e
République vous a offert ce moyen de
gouverner qui n'existe dans quasiment
aucune des grandes démocraties
européennes vous êtes donc venu ici 23
fois à la place que j'occupe pour tel
ind disque rayé reprcher reprocher au
représentants du peuple d'avoir présenté
trop d'amendement d'avoir osé vouloir
débattre sans vous assurer au préalable
qu'ils vteront en faveur de votre texte
de vouloir utiliser une part du temps de
leur mandat pour faire ce pourquoi ils
ont été élus alors que la seule vérité
c'est que vous êtes ici minoritaire pour
appliquer votre politique économique ce
qui démocratiquement devrait vous
conduire à la à la modifier ou à
démissionner
oui madame la Première ministre vous et
votre gouvernement méritez enfin d'être
censuré pour la loi naséabonde que vous
avez imposé ici y compris à vos propres
troupes ce qui me permet à ce stade de
saluer ceux qui s'y sont refusés et de
grâce arrêtez ces arguments politiciens
qui tentent de camoufler votre
capitulation en race campagne devant
l'idéologie de l'extrême droite pour
reprendre les arguments infantiles du
ministre de l'Intérieur cette loi est
méchante vis-à-vis de tous les étrangers
hors Union européenne ce qui accentue
son caractère raciste n'essayez pas par
exemple de faire passer le durcissement
des conditions deroit d'un titre de
séjour prévu par la circulaire V Vals
pour les travailleurs sans papierers
comme un progrès dans cette voie
la version initiale reposait déjà sur le
fond du discours du rassemblement
national qui voit l'immigré comme un
danger permanent rappelons les faits et
j'empreunte pour cela les mots du
sociologue François erand aucune donnée
ne confirme que la France est la
destination privilégiée parmi les
migrants nous sommes très en de ça
dit-il de la part qu'on aurait pu
prendre en Europe autrement dit à ce
stade il n'y a pas de vague migratoire
dans ce pays si nous nous comparons aux
autres pays d'Europe mais plus encore
aux pays du Sud entre eux s'il y a un
problème c'est celui généré par les
conditions indignes d'accueil de
l'immigration que votre loi va encore
durcir elle le faisait déjà dans sa
version première ce qui avait fait dire
à cladon Défenseur des droits qu'il
s'agissait je cite d'un texte d'une
gravité majeure pour les droits
fondamentaux pour chercher une majorité
vous avez donc avalé toutes les
exigences des républicains qui ont
choisi de sauver leur existance en se
faisant le cheval de trois s idées
d'extrême droite et à qui je veux
rappeler qu'une fois utilisé le cheval
de TR a été abandonné prix 1 ces ajouts
sont incontestablement des mesures
d'extrême droite pris dans leur ensemble
c'est son programme conditionnement de
l'ouverture des droits aux prestations
sociales non contributiv évincement des
personnes soumis à une octf du droit à
l'hébergement d'urgence préférence
nationale déchéance de la nationalité
fin de l'automaticité du droit du sol
cautionnement pour les étudiants
extracommunautaires restriction du
regroupement familial engagement de
réformer laame rétablissement du délour
du séjour du séjour du délit de séjour
irrégulier non jeetis plus vous venez
madame la Première ministre d'être la
premi chef de gouvernement d'extrême
droite de ce pays en matière
d'immigration et ce ne sont pas les
propos qui se veulent rassurant que vous
et le chef d'État utilisez pour
expliquer que les pires mesures de cette
loi sont anticonstitutionnelles ce qui
est vrai qui changera le mal que vous
venez de faire si vous voulez nous
convaincre que nous avons encore commun
une trace de cet humanisme que vous
rendiquez madame la Première ministre il
n'y a qu'un seul moyen ne promulguez pas
cette loi je suis certain parce qu'elle
est contraire à nos principes
républicains que cette loi ne sera pas
appliquée ce peuple que vous insultez en
en en permanence en expliquant que vous
ne faites que suivre son opinion saura
vous résister vous verrez mais pour vous
le mal est fait avec cette loi que vous
avez définitivement re vous avez
définitivement rejoint la Corte des
gouvernements néolibéraux qui appliquent
une politique d'extrême droite sans en
être issue vous placez la France dans le
Ploton de tête des gouvernement
appliquant des politiques d'extrême
droite sur le plan discriminatoire et
sécuritaire en Europe et dans le monde
pour sécuriser vénement une politique
ultralibérale inégale et injuste oui
nous venons de vivre un moment de
bascule politique les Diges sont rompus
le bloc que vous incarnez n'hésitera
plus désormais j'en suis convaincu à
aller toujours plus loin dans l'extrême
droitisation de sa politique vous avez
sans doute fait ce choix par tactique
parce que l'Élysée vous l'a imposé mais
vous ou ceux qui vous succéderont
bientôt le feront naturellement cela ne
vous empêchera pas de perdre car en
réalité c'est le macronisme qui est
défit non seulement parce que les gens
préfèrent toujours leurig à la copie
mais parce qu'en ayant repris ces idées
vous avez perdu toute légitimité à
représenter ce barrage face à l'extrême
droite qui a permis au président Macron
d'être élu ce constat fixe par ailleurs
les responsabilités de la gauche à qui
désormais il revient d'être le seul
barrage possible face à l'extrême droite
en incarnant la rupture radicale avec
votre politique néolibérale et la
défense des idéaux républicains qui font
la grandeur de notre pays depuis sa
révolution pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons chers collègues au nom de nos
idéaux républicains je vous invite à
censurer ce gouvernement je vous
remercie monsieur le
Président la parole est à Madame la
vice-présidente Rabo pour le groupe
socialiste pour une durée de 10
minutes
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues cette 23e
motion de censure la dernière de l'année
me donne l'occasion de vous dire
quelques mots de ce qui s'est passé
mardi soir ici dans cet hémicycle le
vote de votre loi immigration constitue
un tournant honteux dans notre histoire
démocratique cette histoire c'est celle
de la Révolution française fondée sur
l'universalité des droits et des devoirs
et sur l'émancipation de l'humain or
votre texte initie un virage dangereux
car il tourne le dos à ces grands
principes vous demandez ainsi à des
étrangers en situation régulière qui
travaillent et qui par conséquent
cotisent d'attendre désormais 2,5 années
pour être éligible aux allocations
familiales et plusieurs mois pour les
allocations logement vous demandez aux
étudiants étrangers de déposer une
caution bancaire pendant la durée de
leurs études faisant de la France le
seul pays le seul pays de l'Europe à
exiger une telle caution avec cette
exigence iniique vous abîmez le
rayonnement séculaire de notre pays par
le savoir par la culture par la pensée
alors oui depuis mardi vous tentez
d'expliquer que tout cela n'est pas si
grave et que vous allez arranger les
choses en incitant le Conseil
constitutionnel à censurer les articles
les plus choquants ou encore en écrivant
des décrets bidons pour contourner les
mesures les plus honteuses de votre loi
dans votre tentative d'échapper au
rassemblement national vous essayez même
de faire croire que votre loi a été
votée sans les lois du rassemblement
national madame la Première ministre
vous êtes suffisamment experte en
mathématique pour savoir que sans les
voix du rassemblement national votre loi
n'aurait pas été votée tout simplement
parce que sans les voix du RN votre
texte aurait obtenu 261 voix pour et 274
voix contre depuis mardi dernier vous
avez pactisé vous avez pactisé madame la
première ministre vous avez pactisé avec
le rassemblement national autour de sa
préférence nationale et cela devient à
jamais le marqueur de votre gouvernement
gouverner un pays c'est choisir entre
deux voix soit se rabougrir autour d'un
petit dénominateur commun sous
l'influence de la peur soit démultiplier
le potentiel du pays cette seconde
option a été très longtemps celle de la
France celle qui rayonne par ses les
idées celle qui est chérie par les
amoureux de la démocratie dans le monde
entier celle qui a constitué un point de
repère pour ceux trop nombreux dont les
droits humains et les libertés
fondamentales sont bafoué choisir entre
ces deux voies s'applique aussi en
économie cette motion de censure en
réponse à votre 493 sur la lecture
définitive du projet de loi de finances
pour 2024 me donne l'occasion d'aborder
cinq points de politique économique
quasiment absent de votre projet de loi
d'abord sur la croissance de notre
valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire la
croissance économique depuis 2017 mes
chers collègues la France figure parmi
les pays européens qui affichent la plus
faible croissance économique et pour
l'année 2022 si les chiffres sont là
mais les chiffres sont là Monsieur le
gardessau je sais que vous n'aimez pas
les chiffres il suffit de prendre les
données statistiques d'Eurostat pour
l'année 2022 pour l'année 2022 elle
figure même dans le dernier tiers dans
le dernier tiers des pays européens pour
la croissance économique cette situation
qui nous affaiblit fragilise désormais
tout le continent européen parce que
avec l'Allemagne la France représente 40
% du PIB européen par conséquent ces
deux pays France et Allemagne ont un
rôle clé à jouer pour tout le continent
européen et lorsqu'on regarde les
données et lorsqu'on regarde les données
pour l'année prochaine nous voyons que à
nouveau nous sommes le 6e pays avec la
plus faible croissance de l'Union
européenne tout ceci est à mettre en
regard ce qui se passe aux États-Unis la
croissance économique va atteindre 5 %
c'est-à-dire 5 % pour les États-Unis il
y a donc une nécessité pour nos deux
économie d'avancer or les deux volets
qui permettent de créer de la valeur
ajoutée dans une économie c'est
l'investissement et le savoir sur
l'investissement il doit y avoir de la
lisibilité dans votre PLF 2024 on n'en
affichz aucune c'est éparpillé de
partout et il n'y a pas de consolidation
qui est entreprise même la commission
EUR EUR même la Commission européenne
demande aux États-membres de faire mieux
sur le savoir votre gouvernement n'a
cessé de reporter l'objectif d'un effort
de recherche publique à 1 % du PIB
désormais vous l'affichez pour 2030
c'est-à-dire dans 7 ans à minima il
faudrait visiser cet objectif pour la
fin du quinquena c'est-à-dire 2027 y
parvenir nécessite d'avoir une
trajectoire budgétaire et lorsqu'on
refait les calculs on voit qu'il
faudrait ajouter 800 millions d'euros de
plus dès l'année 2024 pour la recherche
publique toujours sur le savoir il y a
de semaines l'OCDE a publié les les
résultats de son enquête PISA qui sont
dévastateurs pour la France notamment en
mathématique au-delà de ces résultats
l'OCDE écrit et je la cite contrairement
à 2018 les chefs d'établissement
déclarent en France un manque important
d'enseignants et de personnel non
enseignant dans leurs établissements en
2022 fermé les guillemets or depuis 2017
vous avez pr supprimé 8000 postes dans
le second degré au lieu de changer de
braquer et d'engager une politique
ambitieuse votre budget 2024 poursuit
cette voie dans cette voie avec 1709
suppressions de postes supplémentaires
dans le 1emer degré et 484 dans le
second degré 2ème point sur la
transition écologique et c'est-à-dire
au-delà la structuration de notre
économie on considère aujourd'hui que 45
% de notre PIB de la valeur ajoutée de
notre économie découle de l'économie de
la vie ce qui signifie à contrario que
55 % de notre PIB provient de production
trop carbonée qui ais notre planète bien
entendu nous n'allons pas changer la
donne du jour au lendemain mais établir
une programmation sérieuse et suivie à
votre niveau permettrait d'accélérer un
virage plus que nécessaire troisème
sujet la réduction des inégalités qui
est un fondement indispensable pour la
cohésion de notre société pour aborder
cette question madame la Première
ministre permettez-moi de m'appuyer sur
les données européennes à nouveau
j'invite d'ailleurs à votre gouvernement
à les lire avec l'indice guini qui
mesure le degré d'inégalité dans un pays
donné plus il est élevé plus le pays est
inégalitaire cet indice mes chers
collègues est en constante augmentation
depuis 2017 en constante augmentation
depuis 2017 à l'inverse il s'est réduit
en Allemagne en Allemagne devenant même
inférieur à celui de la France ce qui
signifie qu'au cours des 5 dernières
années l'Allemagne est devenu moins
inégalitaire que notre pays surtout
surtout la France la France est devenue
plus inégalitaire que la moyenne des
pays de l'Union européenne c'est une
première c'est une première dans
l'histoire de notre pays alors toutes
vos lois de finances ont accru ces
inégalités et le projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 ne fait pas exception
puisque vous continuez par exemple à
refuser le crédit d'impôt pour les moins
riches des résidents en éepad porté par
ma collègue Christine res B alors que
vous créez alors que vous créez une méga
niche fiscale pour la FIFA et tous les
salariés des fédérations sportives
internationales 4ème point le logement
qui est le gros échec de votre politique
depuis 2017 les locataires ont perdu
l'équivalent d'un mois d'allocation
logement par an et la réforme de leur
mode de calcul a fait 2 millions de
perdants entre 2020 et 2022 en ayant
réalisé 6 milliards économie sur les
bailleurs sociaux depuis 2018 la
production de logements sociaux chute de
manière continue et la France compte
400000 demandeur de plus qu'au début du
premier quinquenna d'Emmanuel Macron
votre politique fiscale défvorable au
secteur a par ailleurs casser la
dynamique de construction de logement il
y a une chute de 28 % 28 % des permis de
construire délivrés au cours des 12
derniers mois on passe à 300 171000
contre
471000 le nombre de mises en chantier a
elle aussi chuté la filièreedoute 30000
destruction d'emploi enfin toujours au
3e trimestre 2023 les les réservations
nettes chutent de 46 % et les ventes aux
investisseurs particuliers reculent de
58 % c'est du jamais vu dans notre pays
ce projet de loi de finance 2024 aurait
dû signer un rebond pour le logement il
n'en a rien été en redonnant des marges
de manœuvre le 5è point et qui concerne
la valeur travail qui est qui est
aujourd'hui sévèrement grignoté par
l'inflation en cela elle fragilise le
pacte social qui unit le pays car
comment croire au travail si un salaire
ne permet pas de boucler les fins de
mois à de nombreuses reprises nous vous
avons alerté fait des propositions vous
ne nous écoutez pas mais peut-être
allez-vous écouter Linc je vais vous
lire ce que Linc a écrit le 23 novembre
dernier c'était il y a pas si longtemps
je la cite en 2022 la hausse du niveau
de vie ne compense qu'en partie
l'augmentation des dépenses liées à
l'inflation sauf pour les 10 % les plus
aisés le constat est sans appel répondre
à ces enjeux et à ceux de la santé c'est
ce que les députés du groupe socialiste
et apparenté ont fait le 31 octobre
dernier en présentant un contrebudget ce
contrebudget était financé il mettait la
remettait la justice sociale là où vous
l'avez supprimé il portait une ambition
économique sociale et écologique nous
continuerons à le porter à le défendre
dans l'immédiat je vous invite mes
chersè
V la motion de censure proposé face à
votre politique économique je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
vice-présidente la parole est à Monsieur
Pascal Lecamp pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances chers collègues cette année
encore nous nous retrouvons quelques
jours avant Noël j'oserai dire en en
guise de cadeaux d'ultime cadeau de Noël
pour examiner une dernière motion de
censure sur le
PLF cette année encore l'examen du
budget a été une nouvelle fois perturbé
par l'examen de ces motions de censure à
répétition trop souvent marqué par
l'outrance et la mauvaise foi cette
année encore les mêmes arguments
mensongés ont été avancés pour justifier
l'émotion de censure le recours au 493
dans le cadre de l'examen des textes
financiers relèverait du dénis de
démocratie voire même de
l'autoritarisme un article je suis assez
fier de le dire ici à la tribune qui a
été écrit dans la 5e Constitution par
une personne née dans mon village à
civra André Chandernagor ancien ministre
des affaires européennes avec Michel
Debray c'est bon de le savoir c'est lui
qui a écrit cet article et bien chers
collègues sans surprise cette année
encore au groupe démocrate nous
répondrons avec calme et sans froid à
ces manœuvres politiciennes obstinées
qui chaque jour affaiblissent encore
plus la force politique du message porté
par une motion de censure tout d'abord
nous ne pouvons pas vous laisser
affirmer avec un tel àlomb que les
débats parlementaires a été refusés le
PLF 2024 a fait l'objet de plus de 158
heures de débats ces débats furent
toujours très constructifs et argumentés
particulièrement en commission des
finances où la qualité des échanges et
le respect des valeurs de chacun on su
être on su être assuré pardon grâce à la
sérénité au professionnalisme à la fois
du du président coqurel et du rapporteur
général casenu que je veux remercier ici
tout particulièrement ainsi que tous les
administrateurs de la commission des
finances qui ont permis ces débats
chaque groupe a pu exprimer en
commission ses positions claires sur
tous les articles du PLF tous les sujets
cruciaux pour le quotidien de nos
concitoyens y ont été abordés logement
écologie lutte contre la fraude fiscale
mesures d'accompagnement contre
l'inflation soutien au collectivité
territoriale maîtrise des compes public
ces débats ont permis de dégager des
compromis sur un certain nombre de
points dans les deux assemblées avec la
reprise d'amendement de la majorité
comme de
l'opposition extension de l'indemnité
carburant création d'une taxe streaming
rehaussement supplémentaire de la GGF
soutien accru au territoire d'outrem
entre autres ces débats ont aussi
rappelé dans la pratique
quotidienne de nos travaux que les
Français ont choisi en juin 2022 d'élire
une majorité rel dans l'hémicycle dans
ce contexte une soixantaine de textes
ont été adoptés dans une logique de
compromis mais sur un texte aussi
symbolique que le budget les oppositions
politiques paraissent indépassables et
les échanges que nous avons eu en
commission nous l'ONS une nouvelle fois
approuvé dès le début de l'examen du
texte tous les groupes politiques de
l'opposition ont affirmé qu'il
voteraient contre le budget dans ces
conditions il est donc tout à fait faux
de dire que le recours au 3 tue le débat
comme je l'ai rappelé il le Clos en
prenant acte du refus de construire le
compromis c'est d'ailleurs assez
étonnant de vous voir continuer à user
de ces arguments alors que vous avez
refusé le débat sur l'immigration dans
cet hémicycle en votant en conscience et
de concert pour la motion de Roger la
semaine
dernière sur un texte aussi essentiel
que le budget aucune autre voie n'est
possible si nous voulons que la France
ne se retrouve pas à l'arrêt les
premiers on subir les conséquences en
serait les Français nous Senons ainsi
pleinement la première ministre dans
l'usage qu'elle fait de l'outil que la
Constitution lui donne pour ne pas
basculer dans la paralysie de l'action
publique nous regrettons très
sincèrement qu'une nouvelle fois les
posture politique ne nous a pas permis
d'aboutir à un compromis nous aurions
certainement pu nous rassembler sur les
avancées majeures que propose ce budget
pour l'année
2024 je prendrai quelques exemples grâce
à ce budget
et je pense au ministre de l'Agriculture
qui est avec nous aujourd'hui le soutien
à notre agriculture et nos forêts sera
considérablement renforcé afin de
poursuivre et accélérer la transition
écologique dans ces secteurs clés la
mission agriculture alimentation forêt
et affaires rurales bénéficiera pour se
faire d'une augmentation historique de 1
milliard d'euros dont 250 millions
d'euros seront mobilisés pour la
réduction de l'utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires et 45 millions d'euros
déployés en faveur de la mise en place
du Plan a afin de mettre un coup d'arrêt
à la destruction et la dégradation des a
observés depuis un un demi-siècle pardon
enfin des moyens budgétaires sans
précédent seront mobilisés pour protéger
nos forêts des incendies qui se font de
plus en plus régulier et violent comme
vous le savez sous l'effet du
réchauffement climatique le Centre
National de la Propriété Forestière
disposera par exemple de ressources
financières supplémentaires pour
recruter se nouveaux ETP en 2024
grâce à ce budget le soutien à nos
territoires d'outremè sera lui aussi
renforcé comme rarement au cours de ces
dernières années un soutien exceptionnel
de 60 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement sera accordé au conseil
départemental de Mayot le passeport pour
la mobilité en stage professionnel sera
largement étendu et à l'initiative de
notre collègue France gums les moyens du
programme de formation de futur cadres
intitulé cadres d'avenir seront
renforcés à Saint-Martin ce budget
attaque enfin également à la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale une dizaine de
nouveaux outils juridiques présents dans
ce texte doivent permettre à
l'administration fiscal de mieux
détecter et sanctionner les fraudeurs
mieux les détecter en adaptant le cadre
juridique aux enjeux du numérique et
mieux les sanctionner en créant un
régime de sanction gradué applicable à
l'ensemble des fraudes aux aides
publiques ainsi qu'un nouveau délit
d'incitation à la fraude fiscale ce
budget enfin
signe une grande victoire en faveur de
l'équité fiscale avec la transposition
de l'accord de l'OCDE visant assurer un
niveau minimum d'imposition mondiale à
15 % pour les grands
groupes aucun texte n'est parfait nous
le savons tous ici tout particulièrement
en tant que législateur mais le
compromis par définition exige de faire
des concessions au groupe démocrate nous
voulons saluer positivement les avancées
majeures de ce texte même imparfait ce
qui nous empêchera pas de continuer à
défendre certaines propositions que nous
avons faites durant les dernières
semaines en matière de logement nous
portons des mesures de réforme
structurelles pour enfin sortir de la
crise profonde dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui nous espérons que
dans les prochains mois la réforme des
plusvalues immobilières que nous
appelons de nos vœux tout comme le
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
que nous avons auditionné hier matin en
commission sera adopté
en matière de justice fiscale nous
pensons que dans l'entreprise il faut
encourager les bénéfices utiles et
décourager les bénéfices futiles c'est
tout le sens tout le sens de notre
proposition de taxer les programmes de
rachat d'action que nous continuerons à
porter avec le groupe démocrate comme
vous savez madame la Première ministre
nous sommes très attaché à nos idées
presque têtu cela nous empêche pas non
plus de prendre abilité quand la
situation le nécessite en partenaire
indéfectible de la majorité ainsi vous
l'aurez compris le groupe démocrate ne
votera pas cette motion de centure ce
qui nous empêche pas de vous souhaiter à
tous un joyeux Noël et de bonne fête de
fin
d'année merci Monsieur le
camp la parole est à Madame Véronique
louvag pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues dernière
ligne droite pour ce budget 2024 dont
l'examen restera tristement inédit et
largement frustrant puisque finalement
nous n'avons pu nous exprimer en séance
que sur des motions de censure quand
nous attendions un débat sur le fond
projet contre projet amendement contre
amendement nous arrivons donc au bout de
l'examen de ce PLF avec pour finir
l'année en beauté cette éème et ultime
motion de censure du groupe LFI le
groupe LFI qui à force de multiplier les
motions de censure est en train de se
discréditer et de faire perdre tout son
sens au principe même d'une motion de
censure ces motions de censure qui sont
désormais voté dans l'indifférence
générale par à peine une centaine de
députés dont tout le monde a compris
qu'elles étaient systématiquement vooué
à l'échec je ne comptais pas parler ici
de la loi immigration mais
l'intervention de Monsieur H coqurel il
y a quelques instants mis contraint
parce que finalement en citant les
républicains du côté de LFI vous voulez
simplement faire oublier votre
pantalonnade tactique car en votant la
motion de rejet sur l'immigration lundi
dernier vous avez les députés et les
filles contribué nous vous en remercions
à faire adopter un texte de droite
auquel les républicains ont largement
contribué bien plus dur que le texte
initial revenons à cette motion de
censure n'entretenons pas de faux
suspense et disolons disonsle tout de
suite nous ne voterons pas cette motion
de censure pas plus que nous n'avons
voté les quatre précédentes depuis
octobre et ce alors que nous combattons
pourtant ce PLF depuis les bans de
l'opposition la principale raison tient
au fait que la France a besoin d'un
budget fussil insatisfaisant d'ici 11
jours et que nous ne pouvons pas prendre
le risque d'un donne en pleine période
de fête malgré nos profondes divergences
avec le gouvernement nous ne rentrerons
pas dans le jeu dangereux du groupe LFI
un jeu dangereux dans lequel les députés
du rassemblement national sont vos
alliés objectifs pour mener ensemble la
politique du pire vous refusez de voir
que notre pays croule sous les
prélèvements obligatoires dont il est
devenu le champion d'Europe incontestée
vous refusez de voir et monsieur Éric
cocrel l'a confirmé il y a quelques
instants ici à la tribune que le
dérapage de nos finances publiques est
en train de devenir habissal à mesure
que notre dette devient insoutenable
enfin fidèle à notre ADN nous restons
une opposition responsable une
opposition animée par la seule volonté
d'être utile au pays et de défendre les
français pour autant nous déplorons tout
comme vous les conditions d'examen
proprement délétaire de ce budget 2024
et la facilité dans laquelle cette
majorité est tombée en déposant des 493
de plus en plus précoces car ce n'est
pas le 49 3 lui-même qui pose un
problème c'est la méthode du
gouvernement qui a consisté cette année
à se servir du 493 non pas seulement
pour faire adopter un texte mais pour
faire taire ses oppositions je le dis
avec force le débat aura été ici
interdit le débat aura été empêché le
débat aura été censuré par votre
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
pendant l'intégralité de cet automne
budgétaire et nous le dénoncerons en
saisissant le Conseil constitutionnel
rendez-vous compte que nous n'avons des
débattu d'aucun amendement et que nous
n'avons pu voter sur aucun des articles
de la première partie du PLF ni en
première lecture ni en nouvelle lecture
ni en lecture définitive pas un seul
amendement sur les 5000 déposés n'aura
été soumis au vote et sur la seconde
partie nous avons simpblement examiné 7
des 23 missions budgétaires nous n'avons
pas donc pas pu débattre en séance du
logement de la rénovation thermique nous
n'avons pas pu parler du sort des
collectivités territoriales nous n'avons
pas pu aborder le sujet pourtant majeur
de l'inflation qui mine le pouvoir
d'achat de nos compatriotes pas plus que
nous n'avons pu évoquer nos propositions
en terme de baisse de dépenses publiques
et de rééquilibrage des comptes c'est
navrant et quand on met à ce point le
Parlement sous cloche ne vous étonnez
pas quand il reprend sa liberté et vous
met en échec enfin sans l'ombre d'une
discussion et sans vote à l'assemblée
certains dispositifs clairement
dangereux ont été confirmés par les 493
et je pense en particulier à la
réduction de l'abattement dont
bénéficient les locations touristiques
de 71 % à 30 % je dis bien à 30 % et non
50 % suite à une erreur que ne vous
n'avez pas su corriger c'est un coup de
Massie aujourd'hui pour tous ces
français pour qu' la location ponctuelle
représente un coup de pouce bienvenu il
fallait s'attaquer au professionnels de
la location Airbnb en zone tendue or
vous êtes en train ici de taper une
nouvelle fois sur les propriétaires
français monsieur le ministre chargé des
comptes publics vous nous expliquez que
rien ne changera dans l'immédiat j'ose
espérer que cet amendement sera
rectifieré l'année prochaine avant la
déclaration fiscale du printemps 2025 à
l'heure des compes et suite au 5493 qui
ont été activés sur ce PLF le sold de
budgétaire de l'État s'est en réalité
creusé de 2,4 milliards d'euros de ce
fait les dépenses passent de
1575 milliards en 2023 à 1624 en 2024
effectivement derrière cela nous
confirme qu'il s'agit d'un budget en 3D
un budget de la dépense du déficit et de
la dette à avec un niveau de dépenses
publique qui reste exorbitant à
55,9 % du PIB avec un déficit à 4,4 % du
PIB qui ne baisse pas et qui est en
train de devenir le pire déficit en
Europe tous les pays de l'Union
européenne auront un déficit public sous
les 3 % du PIB d'ici à 2025 tous tous
sauf nous le Portugal chip la Croatie ou
l'Irlande sont déjà en excédent à
l'équilibre l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas et
même la Grèce sont déjà sous les 3 %.
les Espagne sera en 2024 l'Italie en
2025 et la Belgique en 2026 tout le
monde a pris le train du désendettement
sauf nous notre dette continuera donc
d'augmenter dangereusement avec un
nouveau recours à l'emprunt de plus de
285 milliards d'euros en 2024 un montant
jamais atteint la France sera alors le
3isème pays le plus endetté d'Europe
derrière l'Italie et la Grèce et pendant
que notre dette dépasse désormais les
3000 milliards d'euros la charge de la
dette explose elle était de 31 milliards
en 2021 sera de 57 milliards en 2024 et
pourrait dépasser les 81 milliards en
2027 alors qu'elle deviendra le poste de
dépense le plus important de l'État
songez à tout ce que nous pourrions
faire pour les Français avec cet argent
enfin notre taux de prélèvement
obligatoire ne baisse toujours pas
contrairement aux promesses
présidentielles vous avez d'ailleurs
beau jeu de nous jurer la main sur le
cœur qu'il n'y aura pas de nouvelles
taxes avant de nous annoncer finalement
une taxe supplémentaire sur le streaming
musicale une taxe d'ailleurs qui va
pénaliser tout spécialement notre
champion français dieser qui est
pourtant le seul avec Spotify à financer
réellement la création d'autant qu'au
même moment vous faites un gigantesque
cadeau fiscal à une poignée de
fédération sportive internationale via
un amendement déposé en Cathy min au
mépris de la transparence dont vous vous
faisiez pourtant les chantres en 2017
c'est sans doute ça votre en même temps
dont nous voyons chaque jour un peu plus
l'impasse dans lequel il nous mène enfin
puisque la répétition c'est l'art de la
pédagogie je profite de cette dernière
tribune pour tenter de vous convaincre
une dernière fois de l'impératif de
rétablir nos comptes publics tant ils
ont atteint un niveau critique en effet
le poids de la dépense publique n'aura
jamais été aussi élevé n'aura jamais été
aussi élevé que sous le quinquenat
d'Emmanuel Macron il est aujourd'hui
deux fois supérieur à ce qu'il était en
2019 pour 2024 c'est déjà trop tard
hélas le Paris est perdu puisque comme
le constate le président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques ce PLF contient
peu de mesures d'économie structurelle
malgré le premier millésime des revues
de dépenses organisées en
2023 monsieur le ministre en charge des
comptes publics vous avez annoncé une
indispensable baisse des dépenses
publiques de 12 milliards d'euros en
2025 pour que nos finances publiques
soient en corrélation finalement avec la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques vous le savez 12 milliards
c'est beaucoup c'est un engagement qui
nécessite courage volonté et des
termination or vous en manquez à ce
stade puisque pour 2024 sur les 16
milliards d'économie annoncé par le
gouvernement près de 90 % monsieur le
ministre repose uniquement sur
l'extinction déjà annoncé des dépenses
exceptionnelles pour 2025 vous devez
donc accepter de changer complètement de
braquer et comme la diminution de la
dépense publique n'est pas dans l'ADN du
gouvernement nous vous avons fait des
propositions ambitieuses avec les
députés les républiqu
que je vous invite à reprendre
2024 commence dans 11 jours
promettez-nous pour un cadeau de Noël
promettez-nous qu'elle sera vraiment
l'année de la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
et qu'elle permettra de déboucher enfin
sur un PLF de baisse réelle des dépenses
la balle est dans votre camp vous avez
perdu beaucoup de crédit mais nous
continuons d'espérer une inflexion
majeure de votre part j'en profite
puisque c'est la dernière tribune sur ce
PLF pour vous féliciter monsieur le
ministre pour ce premier budget à la
tête de votre ministère j'en profite
également pour remercier tous les agents
administrateurs collaborateurs qui nous
ont épaulé dans notre tâche depuis
septembre très joyeux Noël et bonne fête
à tous je vous remercie merci Madame
louvagi la parole est à madame Lise
manier pour le groupe horizon et
apparenté
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous y
sommes la dernière motion de censure
pour la dernière séance de cette année
2023 on pourrait presque entendre
chanter Eddie Mitchel dans cet hémicycle
et comme c'est la dernière je voudrais
en profiter pour remercier au nom du
groupe horizon le président de la
commission des finances et le rapporteur
général du budget
pour l'immense travail qu'ils ont fourni
et qui nous a permis de tenir notre rôle
et nos débats en commission des finances
et je veux aussi remercier l'ensemble
des collaborateurs nos collaborateurs
parlementaires nos collaborateurs de
groupes les collaborateurs de la
commission des finances de la séance et
plus globalement de toute l'assemblée
nationale évidemment les collaborateurs
ministériel permettez-moi d'adresser un
merci plus personnel à Celia et Léo de
Matignon à Benjamin et Malo Yanis et
Damien à Bercy et Elodie et Mathieu ici
à mes
côtés en ce 21 décembre 2023 je souhaite
évidemment vous souhaiter de très belles
fêtes de fin d'année à chacune et à
chacun qu'elle vous offre des moments de
repos et de répis je crois bien mérités
et surtout beaucoup de bonheur partager
avec vos proches madame la Première
ministre vous avez déjà entendu quatre
fois les arguments des uns et des autres
sur votre projet de loi de finances 2024
et objectivement je vais vous épargner
cet exercice répétitif madame la
Première ministre vous le savez le
groupe horizon soutient votre projet loi
de finances pour 2024 et ne votera donc
pas cette motion de censure je vous
remercie joyeux Noël à tous merci Madame
manier
efficace la parole est à Madame Sandrine
Rousseau pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste c'est pas complètement sûr
monsieur le ministre qu'on continue avec
l'esprit de novelle madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres madame la Présidente chers
collègues beaucoup se demandent ce
qu'est le macronisme il apparaît comme
une sorte d'objet politique un peu non
identifié et comme nous n'en pouvons
plus d'entendre ça en continue et ben
nous allons aider les éditorialistes
politiques qui s'interroge pour définir
ce qu'est le macronisme alors en fait
c'est cinq choses assez simple la
première c'est faire la guerre aux
pauvres mais alors vraiment hein une
véritable guerre au pauvres pas une
petite bataille mais vraiment quelque
chose d'incessant quotidien loi sur les
retraites suppression des critères de
pénibilité décalage de l'âge de départ
réforme de l'assurance chômage
augmentation des possibilités de
radiation diminution des allocations
pour tout le monde réforme du RSA
création du travail sans salaire
sanction si vous n'acceptez pas 0 € pour
vivre suppression des emplois aidés
diminution de 5 € des aPL ponction de
l'argent du livrat destiné au logement
social refus du blocage des loyers ou de
leur encadrement loi antiquat au cas où
certains chercheraiit à rester alors
qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens de payer
affaiblissement du service public de
tous les services publics organisation
d'une concurrence déloyale entre
servicees publics et secteur privé
lucratif car Macron crise de l'hôpital
public de l'école publique
dématérialisation des services public en
ligne pour les rendre encore plus
inaccessibles refus du repas à 1 € pour
tous les étudiants ponction sur les
pécules des enfants enfant placé et
maintenant possiblement suppression des
allocations familiales aux parents
supposément défaillants parce qu'on va
se le dire ça va toucher les parents
pauvres hein parce que les parents
riches eux on dira que leurs enfants
sont disruptifs ils sont pas délinquants
plafond d'indemnisation en cas de
licenciement abusif c'est vrai que
perdre son boulot abusivement fallait
bien limiter l'indemnisation suppression
des droits au chômage en cas d'abondant
de poste et évidemment serit sur le
gâteau apothéose de cette guerre aux
pauvres c'est de faire des plus
vulnérables des pauvres les étrangers la
cause de tout festival la liste est
longue je m'arrête là pour procéder au
second point donner aux riches les
flatter les accueillir suppression de
l'ISF pas d'encadrement des retraites
chapeau pas de surtaxation des profits
pas de restriction des dividendes niche
F niche fiscale pour les locations de
courte durée enrichissement et honé des
plus riches durant le covid et depuis
pas de réforme fiscale exonération des
cotisation patronnale ajouter à cela
quelques légions d'honneur qui font
monte à la France pouillané de par Dieu
parce que oui c'est ces légions
d'honneur là font honte à la France 3
incapacité à penser la crise
écologique où sont les 60 milliards
d'euros demandé par le rapport
pisaniféie l'isolation des logements la
sortie du pétrole l'alternative à la
voiture la gratuité des transports
collectifs la fin des pesticides la
diminution des déchets la gestion
partagée de l'eau la fin de le de
l'urbanisation bref un impensé
écologique 4 le macronisme c'est un mode
de gouvernement alors Emmanuel Macron
sait tout il sait mieux que tout le
monde il a raison toujours et même quand
il a tort il a raison ne jamais perdre
ellisabeth borne vous lui avez emboîé le
pas dans cette course folle qui
transforme un barrage supposé en
autoroute vous vouliez vous maintenir
vous ne vouliez que ça vous ne vouliez
pas perdre la face rester durer ne pas
céder vous avez l'impression de gagner
des batailles mais vous perdez une
guerre et pas des moindres celle de la
République de sa comporte de sa Concorde
de votre honneur de vos valeurs vous
n'avez même pas la
dessence vous n'avez même pas la s de
considérer que ce que vous avez entre
les mains est un bien précieux
l'élection vous oblige disiez-vous mais
au fond il n'y a que votre volonté
farouche de pouvoir continuer à siéger
sur ces bancs qui vous animent tel est
le portrait de tel le portrait de Dorian
Gry vous affichez une image présentable
mais derrière le rideau vos portraits ce
que nous décrochons des murs des mairies
finiront mité par la compromission vous
n'êtes pas digne tout au plus êtes-vous
de petits gestionnaires sans âme ce sont
ceux-là précisément qui sont les pires
les plus dangereux c'est comptables qui
tiennent la porte quand les matins bruns
se pointent 5e chose 5e élément de
description du macronisme les ceris sur
le gâteau accuser la gauche d'être
responsable de tout c'est facile
tranquille faites les pires choses les
plus immonde et comme mettre les
étrangers comme figure de toutes nos
passions tristes flatter l'extrême
droite pour ce qu'elle a de pire et
dites de manière constante dans tous les
médias c'est la faute de la gauche tout
ça mais la gauche elle est là ici dans
l'hémicycle dans la rue dans les
associations les collectivités qui
résistent elle est dans la désobéissance
civile nous sommes là et même si vous le
ne le voulez pas et bien nous sommes
encore là parce qu'au fond du fond ce
que veulent les gens ce n'est pas
d'appuyer sur la tête de celles et ceux
qui peinent à sortir la tête de l'eau
fustile des étrangers ce que veulent les
Français et Françaises au fond c'est de
la dignité de l'égalité des services
publics la santé le logement la
fraternité et enc mieux la delphité
parce que non ici comme ailleurs le
masculin ne sera jamais notre
neutre merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
Rousseau la parole est à Monsieur Dav
pour pour le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et
républicaine
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Michel Castellani pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outreemire et
territoire
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances monsieur rapporteur général mes
chers collègues l'exercice budgétaire on
le sait un exercice compliqué entre 2020
et 2022 les finances de l'État se sont
largement détérioré d'abord en raison
des mesures exceptionnelles relatives à
la crise sanitaire et au confinement
ensuite dans la protection des
entreprises et du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages face à la crise de l'énergie
les difficultés conjoncturelles et les
choix budgétaires nous mènent
aujourd'hui à un déficite de 171
milliards et à l'émission de 270
milliards d'euros en 2024 le déficit
sera de 147 milliards nous emprunterons
285 milliards sur les marchés et nous
Pons 51 milliards de d'euros d'intérêt
51 milliards d'euros d'intérêts on
comprend la faiblesse que représente ces
dizaines de milliards d'intérêts et éad
hors de France nous
avons avons débattu en commission des
finances pas plus tard qu'hier et
certains soutiennent qu'il est de bonnes
politiqu car plus le marché est large
plus les taux sont avantageux je veux
vous le dire ce raisonnement est un non
sens macro-économique non sens mieux
vaudrait en effet une souscription plus
élevée mais plus
autocentrée que l'on imagine ce que ces
dizaines de milliards annuels
représentent potentiellement de perte en
matière de consommation d'investissement
de richesse d'emploi et une finé de
revenus euh pour les finances publiques
ça c'est un débat qui va falloir
reprendre et nous veillerons à ce qu'il
soit
repris plus largement notre groupe
estime que la programmation budgétaire
n'est pas optimal d'abord sur les
recettes nous pensons comme d'autres
groupes que le gouvernement aurait pu
rechercher davantage de solutions de
financement le groupe lot a proposé
plusieurs solutions qui auraiit pu
rapporter des milliards d'euros sans
peser ni sur les TPE PME ni sur les age
de classe moyenne et notamment
l'augmentation de deux points de la
fiscalité sur les revenus du capital
financier et l'extension de la taxe sur
les transactions financières ces
nouveaux impôts auraient concernés en
très grande majorité les ménages les
plus aisés ils auraient marqué une
volonté politique ferme d'encadrer la
financiarisation de l'économie des
dérives financières qui en découlent et
ces dividendes extravagant avec d'autres
mesures cela aurait pu rapporter au
moins 6 milliards d'euros un autre
combat est celui de de la réduction des
dépenses exemple parmi d'autres le
crédit d'impôt recherche c'est un
dispositif efficace et utile mais trop
coûteux qu'il convientent d'aménager
pour en supprimer les indiscutables
effets d'è le gouvernement a fait le
choix de ne pas améliorer les recettes
et d'augmenter les dépenses on comprend
que cela ne peut pas en toute hypothèse
mener à une amélioration de la situation
financière sauf à imaginer un
hypothétique sursaut de croissance autre
point important le gouvernement a privé
le Parlement de ses prérogatives
fiscales et budgétaires courira au 493
sur le projet de loi des finances
revientent à confier à l'administration
la gestion des affaires du pays les les
parlementaires sont privés de toute
possibilité d'amendement et ne peuvent
même plus exprimer leur point de vue et
leurs
proposition la commission des finances
reste donc le seul organe parlementaire
où le débat est possible et encore
encore sachant que le 493 va tomber les
groupes sur charge la commission
d'amendement redondants d'autant plus
rapidement expédié que l'on agit on le
sait en délai contraint paradoxalement
le Gouvernement présente cet état de faê
comme une obstruction et justifie ainsi
son utilisation du 493 on comprend que
tout ça n'est guerre positif le
gouvernement aurait pu choisir une autre
voie j'en veux pour preuvve la loi des
finances rectificatives de fin 22 la loi
de fin de gestion pour 23 adopté dans
cet hémicycle 1493 la négociation est
donc possible et constitue la base même
du fonctionnement
démocratique alors pourquoi avoir
déclenché le 493 avant même les
explications de vote sur la première
partie pourquoi n'avoir pas cherché un
consensus minimal sans doute le
gouvernement veut-il éviter d'affronter
les contrepropositions qui émergent au
sein même de sa propre majorité relative
je n'oublie pas que le groupe démocrate
a porter des propositions parfois plus
radicales que Cell de mon groupe en
commission l'indexation différencié du
barê de l'impôt sur le revenu sur
l'inflation la création d'une taxe de 1
% sur les rachats d'action ou encore le
maintien en l'état du pré àau zéro ces
amendem ont été adoptés en commission
des finances d'ailleurs de même à
plusieurs députés des groupes horizon
Renaissance ont fait des propositions
judicieuses né de leur réflexion et puis
aussi de la connaissance concrète du
terrain le 493 Balet ses voix
dissonnantes tout en faisant porter le
chapeau aux oppositions c'est c'est sans
doute de bonnes guerr mais bien peu
satisfaisant dans ce contexte difficile
le groupe lot s'est battu en commission
comme dans les couloirs pour obtenir ce
qu'il croit juste et nécessaire une
victoire se reconduction l'extension du
chèque carburant en 2023 le gouvernement
en effit ouvert un dispositif temporaire
pour aider les Françaises et les
Français qui utilisent leur voiture pour
se rendre à leur travail ce dispositif
était limité à la moitié des ménages et
le manque de communication a entraîné un
non recours massif seul des 4 des 10
millions de bénéficiaires potentiels ont
effectivement encaissé cette aide par
l'action de notre groupe plus d'un
million et demi de travailleurs
supplémentaires bénéficieront de ce
chèque en 2024 et je le précise nous ne
souhaitons naturellement pas
conditionner ce chèque à un prix à la
pompe je tiens d'ailleurs bien sûr ici à
remercier la première ministre le
ministre Thomas casenav pour leur écoute
sur ce sur ce point particulier écoute
quelquefois relative d'ailleurs
autre autre progrès à l'actif du groupe
lot la redevance eau potable payée par
les particuliers à mayottte sera
suspendu nous regrettons d'ailleurs que
l'archipel gadeloupin ne bénéficie pas
de cette disposition comme çaa été sans
doute légitime par ailleurs la
suppression du malus écologique pour les
S10 a été fort heureusement préservé de
leur côté les plafonds de taxes affecté
aux chambres de commerce et d'industrie
des métiers de l'artisanat d'agriculture
ont été augmentés bien que leur
contribution à l'effort budgétaire
collectif reste quand même prignant je
salue évidemment la rédaction actuelle
de la réforme des meublés de tourisme
ainsi que celle du dispositif relatif à
la libération du foncier vous savez
d'ailleurs c'est une parenthèse que la
course est soumise à des contraintes
démographiques et sociétal particulière
des dispositifs propres à l'Hexagone ne
peuvent s'y appliquer tel quel euh la
spéculation immobilière désorganisant
chez nous encore désorganisant
profondément la vie économique et
sociale
les améliorations du zonage de futur ZRR
sont également importantes de même que
la hausse de la DGF de 100 millions
d'euros et l'abandnement du fond d'aide
pour les départements par ailleurs nous
avons poussé pour augmenter les crédits
dédiés à l'expérimentation zéro chômeur
longue durée obtenu plusieurs
dispositions pour la Guadeloupe et
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon le bénéfice de
la dotation particulière élu locale pour
les communes de moins de 1000 habitants
la reconduction de contribution sur la
rente int marginale des producteurs cité
adopté dans la rédaction du rapporteur
général doit également être
cité je voudrais rappeler aussi deux
grandes déceptions la première c'est la
non transformation de la réduction
d'impôts pour les résidents en épad en
un crédit d'impôt et ensuite le rejet de
l'augmentation des crédits dédiés à la
revalorisation et l'augmentation des AES
porté par notre collègue Béatrice descan
ces deux demandes avaient été largement
adoptées en commission vous les avez
malheureusement pas
reprise en tant qu'élu de la Corse je
voudrais être entendu en tant qu'élu de
la Corse j'exprime ma satisfaction de
constater que vous avez particulièrement
prise en compte partiellement prise en
compte les divers surcout qui pèent sur
les transports entre l'île et le
continent par l'attribution d'un
complément de dotation de continé
territoriale sur le fond il conviendrait
d'aller vers la mise à plat de tous les
dispositifs fiscaux
qui se sont accumulés au fil du temps
qui sont chevêtre qui ne sont pas
dépourvu d'ffets pervers et le
remplacement par un statut système
fiscal unique de social et de
développement c'est une demande que nous
réitérons en permanence que donc je
soulève à nouveau ici par ailleurs et
plus largement on sait que le Président
de la République s'est engagé il y a
quelques semaines sur la question de
l'autonomie de la Corse je veux le
redire une fois de plus cette évolution
institutionnelle ne répond pas à un
besoin de singularité
elle peut constituer une réponse plus
adaptée que le cadre actuel aux
problèmes économiques sociaux culturels
historiques que rencontrent les Corses
elle suppose une définition claire à la
fois des compétences transférées et la
maîtrise de leur financement ce qui est
indispensable il convient de régler
cette question et pour cela de renouer
le fil du processus de beauau
voilà les quelques remarques que nous
tenions à formuler je dirais pour
conclure donc que nous considérons ce
budget imparfait même s'il a été
amélioré je l'ai dit nous regrettons sa
méthode
d'élaboration nous souhaitons à l'avenir
des débat budgétaire inscrit dans
l'esprit de la démocratie et qui
respecte en toute hypothèse les
prérogatives de notre assemblée voilà je
vous remercie merci Monsieur
Castellani la parole est à Monsieur
davier pour le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et
républicaine madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre chers
collègu vous avez refusé le débat vous
n'avez pas rempli votre rôle de
parlementaire vous avez abaissé la
fonction de député pour faire un coup
politique tous ces mots nous les avons
entendus de votre part madame la
Première ministre de la part de votre
gouvernement tantant car ses effets de
manche de masqué pour soumission votre
soumission au projet profondément
réactionnaire de la droite sur
l'immigration et puis après nous avoir
accusé de tous les mots comme pour vous
laver de vos péchés vous revenez vers
nous pour prononcer votre 23e 493 ce
gouvernement s sous du débat du
cheminement démocratique de la
construction avec les parlementaires
nous prve une dernième fois de tout cela
sur ce petit sujet politique qui est
celui du vot du budget de la nation
attention cette figure est effectuée par
des professionnels du contortionnisme ne
le reproduisez pas chez vous quelle
hypocrisie la 5e République n'a n'a plus
aucun souffle l'Assemblée nationale se
trouve dans un clair obscur dont surgit
le pire les commissions mixtes paritaire
se déroule à matigon voire à l'Élysée et
les mathématiques se trouvent maltraités
pour prouver qu'un texte n'est pas voté
grâce au voix du RN le gouvernement
navigue à vu il n'y a plus aucun cap
plus aucune anticipation il subit les
événements il il fait l'unanimité dans
les groupes d'opposition de droite et
d'extrême droite pour voter son texte
sur l'immigration mais il ne parvient
même plus à convaincre dans sa propre
majorité un coup à gauche un coup à
droite c'était votre idée d'une
politique qui devait faire avancer le
bateau France mais finalement pire que
les rondes dans l'eau le bateau France
prend l'eau de partout il prend l'eau
jusqu'à jusqu'à reier ce qui fait comme
le dit votre ancien ministre de la Santé
c'estes mur porteur madame la Première
ministre votre gouvernement n'est plus
qualifié pour diriger ce pays nous ne
voulons pas voir sa battre sur les
immigrés de notre pays des vieilles
mesures du FN puis du RN nous souhaitons
pas voir s'appliquer vos budgets
supprimant des milliers de postes de
professeur nous nous opposons au
démantellement de l'hôpital public votre
gouvernement nous mène droit à la
catastrophe pour notre pays un pays qui
compte plus de 9 millions de pauvres un
pays qui voit des milliers d'enfants
dormir dans la rue un pays où étudiants
familles retraités travailleurs se côtoi
aux distributeurs aux distributions
alimentaires comme ce PLF y répond
comment ce PLF y répond quelles sont les
mesures que vous avez prises pour y
remédier la retraite les baisses
d'impôts pour les plus riches les coupes
dans Assur chômage tout cela est
effectué avec une célérité exemplaire
par contre pour ce qui est du reste il
est urgent d'attendre cette motion de
censure nous la souhaitons porteuse d'un
espoir l'espoir d'une alternative qui
serait issue des i l'espoir d'une
alternative qui apporterait des réponses
concrètes structurel aux aspirations
d'une majorité de nos concitoyenes et
concitoyens qui voient leur pouvoir de
vivre c'est fondré leur service public
sacrifié leur environnement se dégradé
l'espoir finalement d'un changement de
modèle économique et social loin des
réponses simplies utilisant le ressort
bien connu de la xénophobie pour faire
porter la responsabilité sur le dernier
arrivé ou bien celui qui ne vous
ressemble pas c'est l'abolition d'un
système profond inégalitaire à la
recherche à tout près du profit que nous
portons nous remettons l'humain au cœur
des politiques publiques le salarier au
cœur de l'entreprise le patient au cœur
de l'hôpital le bénévole au cœur de son
association l'élève au cœur de l'école
ce budget ne traduit pas nos priorités
politiques il répond rien aux enjux de
notre époque et pire encore il se place
au service de politique publique que
nous combattons ardemment la gauche les
progressistes les femmes et les hommes
qui dans leur diversité croi en la
République sociale aux valeurs
humanistes sont ici par notre voix nous
ne laisserons pas tranquillement
dialoguer avec les diverses nuances de
droite de ce pays pour faire passer vos
mauvaises mesures le budget de l'État
est C dresser pour l'année à venir les
grandes lignes de des politiques
économiques et budgétaires de notre pays
c'est donc nous pouvons en convenir un
sujet d'importance pourtant à une minute
de débat n'aura pas été permis en séance
pour la première partie à peine quelques
heures sur la seconde avecexamen des
mississions entamé mais jamais terminé
pour la nouvelle lecture et la lecture
définitive même les interventions
général était de trop pour les censurs
de la majorité et du
gouvernement la réalité aura en effet
été cruel à entendre pour vous à l'heure
où les ministres de l'économie et du
budget dévoilent dévoilent firement un
budget hère comprenant 16 milliards
d'euros pour satisfaire la Commission
européenne et les agences de notation
dans ces conditions monsieur le ministre
ce son les faits comment ce budget
peut-il répondre aux urgences sociales
auxquelles nous nous faisons face à à
commencé par la première d'entre elle
celle du pouvoir d'achat on n a toujours
pas répondu l'inflation cumulée en 2 ans
dans l'Hexagone atteint près de % et
c'est bien pire encore dans les
territoires dit d'reemè et je rappelle
que Monsieur le Ministre la délégation
vous envoyé des invitations pour
échanger justement sur cela on a eu
comme réponse de la part de vos
collaborateurs un bon courage faites
face à cette inflation galopante les
salaires n'ont pas suivi si bien que le
nombre de nos concitoyens se retrouve
désormais au niveau du SMIC or madame la
Première ministre on ne vit pas avec un
sal au SMIC à forcerie lorsque l'emploi
qu'on occupe s'effectue à temps partiel
de manière générale comme de nos
concitoyens comme beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ne peuvent plus vivre de
leur travail comme le montrent les 2
millions de travailleurs pauvres sur ce
point le présent PLF et plus
généralement les textes budgétaires de
cette année constituent une nouvelle
occasion manquée pour agir de manière
contraignante sur les salaires nous le
regrettons cette situation conduit à
accentuer un peu plus encore les
inégalités économiques 1000 milliards
d'euros de patrimoine pour les plus
grosse fortune un record plus de 10
millions de personnes sur le de pauvreté
encore en record je tiens à préciser
pour Mayot c'est 77% de la population et
en Guyane c'est 53 % de la population
comme l'ont montré nos collègues mat et
sensu ces inégalités grainene
aujourd'hui notre société qui petit à
petit redevient une société de rentier
et d'héritier une société figée qui ne
permet plus la mobilité sociale à
l'heure où la nécessité d'une justice
d'une juste répartition de l'impôt se
fait de plus en plus présente vous vous
obstinez à refuser toute mesure allant
dans ce sens à commencé par une
contribution exceptionnelle de très haut
patrimoine pour financer la transition
écologique une mesure qui semble
aujourd'hui plus que consensuelle la la
juste répartition de l'impôt est la
seule à même garantir la souscription de
tous au contrat social qui nous liit et
et à son corolaire indispensable celui
du consentement de
l'impôt le financement de la transition
écologique que ça soit de la rénovation
d'habitat le renouvellement de nos
infrastructures de transport le
développement des mobilités douces la
transition agricole mais aussi le
développement des services publics de
proximité tous ces enjeux nécessitent
aujourd'hui des besoins financier aux
antipodes de la course aux économies à
laquelle vous vous adonnez ces besoins
sont renforcés dans les territoires
d'iloutr m dont je suis issu où la
fracture avec le territoire hexagonal
s'avère grandissante les crédits
supplémentaires que vous accordez à ces
territoire sont très loin de très
suffisants pour per les retards de
développement que nous subissons depuis
trop longtemps la précarité du logement
l'ampleur de l'habitat indine les bid en
ville qui enfle à vue d'œil l'état
pitoilable des infrastructures notamment
routières et encore lorsqu'elles
existent l'accès à l' potable
complètement entravé voire inexistant
loin d'être de simples statistiques ces
carences profondes affectent le
quotidien des centaines de milliers de
vos concitoyens ultrarins car oui ils
sont français comme vous il n déplais à
ceux d'entre vous qui voi l'homme noir
un étranger éternel qui conviendrait
d'embarquer dans dans un charter les
fractures sociales dans notre pays se
creusent c'est à celle-ci que vous
devriez vous attaquer et non à celle
crée de toute pièces par les théoriciens
du Grand remplacement et du choc de
civilisation je finirai mon propos en
vous disant une chose l'entre soit tu je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur
ran la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur général jean-ren casen pour
le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues alors chers collègues vous
nous reprochez vous reprochez à la
première ministre l'utilisation du
493 pardon elle fait comme les 15
premier ministres de la 5e République je
vais en citer quelquesuns Morois Fabius
rard cresson bergovois Vals chers
collègues de gauche avez-vous un
reproche à leur faire et encore eux ils
avaient une majorité é absolue vous
reprocher aussi de s'approcher du record
de France détenu par Michel rard c'est
c'est c'est assez vrai mes chers
collègues vous détenez vous des records
du monde vous êtes champion du monde en
motion de reget préalable mise au voix
42 42 fois et cette semaine c'était
encore une ultime tentative de museler
le débat comme vous le dites si bien
vous êtes aussi champion du monde en
matière de motion de censure 29 en un an
et demi et toujours sans succès et
autant vos premières motions de censure
avait de la gueule si vous me permettez
l'expression elles avaient du souffle
elles étaient signées présenté voté par
239 députés autant les dernières sont
euh inaudibles
incolore
indolor vous proposez des motions de
censure par automatisme pour continuer à
créer le chaos mais vous n'y croyez
vous-même même plus il n a quelques
dizaines de députés pour l'assigner deux
ou trois députés pour assister au débat
vous n'y croyez même plus vous-même dans
quelques minutes nous pousserons cette
potion de censure repousserons cette
potion de censure et adopteront de fait
de manière définitive le budget pour
2024 il suffit de constater que face à
la majorité présidentielle il n'y a
aucune majorité crédible pour voter un
budget vous nous rappelez en B boucle
que nous sommes une majorité relative
merci pour l'info ça ne nous avait pas
échappé les résultats de juin
2022 et dès les premiers jours sous la
responsabilité de la première ministre
nous avons réussi à créer des majorités
sur chacun des textes quelquefois avec
la droite ù la porte est légèrement
ouverte beaucoup plus rarement à gauche
car votre porte est fermée votre porte
est fermée fermée à l'écoute fermée au
dialogue fermé à la construction pour
l'intérêt de notre pays et maintenant
vous nous traitez à l'envie de minorité
présidentielle avec un peu de mépris de
dédain de suffisance j'en déduis donc
chers collègues que vous êtes la
majorité non présidentielle mais vous
gardez bien de nous expliquer comment
vous composez cette majorité non
présidentielle et bien je vais vous le
dire elle va de Mathilde panneau à
Martine Le Pen Marine Le Pen imaginons
euh cette majorité non présidentielle au
pouvoir imaginons le budget
2024 de Jean-Philippe Tangui ministre
des comptes publics et des dépenses
populistes un budget qui exenère d'empôt
les Français de moins de 30 ans qui sont
fortunés ou pas le budget qui baisse la
TVA sur l'énergie et les produits
alimentaires etcit créit des pertes
supérieur à 20 milliards d'euros sans
aucun bénéfice pour les Français un
budget qui s'en prend à la presse en
supprimant la battement fiscal pour les
journalistes par exemple heureusement au
sein de cette majorité non
présidentielle son ministre de tutelle
manuel bonpart ministre de l'économie et
des impôts veille au grain veille au
grain pardon pour combler les dizaines
de milliards d'euros de dépenses et de
moindre recettes de son ministre des
comptes publiques il y a dans ce PLF
imaginer ou augmenter près de 50 taxes
différences pour les entreprises et pour
les Français c'est l'asphyie fiscale
augmentation des impôts sur les
entreprise augmentation des impôts de
production augmentation des droits de
succession augmentation de la taxe de
séjour rétablissement de la redevance
télé rétablissement de la taxe
d'habitation et j'en passe et des
meilleurs mais c'est aussi un amendement
poussé par le ministre de l'Agriculture
végétarienne emeri Caron qui crée une
réduction d'impôts pour les Françaises
et les Français qui réclament avoir des
animaux de compagnie cet attelage
incongru de cette majorité non
présidentielle qui va de l'extrême
droite à extrême gauche uni dans sa
volonté de renverser le gouvernement
c'est son visage c'est votre projet
monsieur couom alors il est aisé d'être
dans l'opposition où les grands parleurs
sont les petits faiseurs l'opposition
qui amende sans limite 20000 amendements
dans le budget cette année sans se
soucier des faux espoirs créé auprès des
Français l'opposition ou la capsule
vidéo et la petite victoire politicienne
ont plus de valeur que le compromis au
service de nos Français l'opposition
davantage présente sur les réseaux
sociaux que dans l'hémicycle ou en
commission mais laissons de côté mais
laissons de côté la politique cauchemar
quelques instants laissons de côté ce
qui s'agite et parlons de ceux qui
agissent le budget pour 2024 sera
définitivement adopté dans quelques
minutes et en tant que rapporteur
général de la commission des finances je
m'en réjouis il s'agit d'un texte de
responsabilité équilibré c'est un texte
qui porte la triste triple
responsabilité du gouvernement et de
notre majorité présidentielle
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la maîtrise
des finances publi responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la transition écologique et
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Français
d'abord première priorité la maîtrise de
nos finances publiques afin de ramener
notre déficit public à 2,7 % du PIB en
2027 je ne la prends à personne nous
faisons face à un contexte économique
compliqué dououblé d'une situation
géopolique plus que tendue une bonne
dizaine de pays en Europe sont cette
année en récession et même si la France
fait mieux que ses voisins européens
mieux en croissance mieux en contrôle de
l'inflation il est vital que nous soyons
responsables nous devons maintenir une
trajectoire saine pour nos finances
publiques tout en poursuivant les
investissements nécessaires à notre pays
mes chers collègues on voulant censurer
le gouvernement c'est à la crédibilité
et à la souveraineté de la France que
vous vous en
prenez deuxème investissement majeur
notre transition écologique ce sont près
de 40 milliards d'euros qui ont été
dédiés qui lui sont dédiés dans ce PLF 7
milliards de plus qu'en 2023
concrètement c'est une croissance des
programmes plus 500 millions pour ma
prime Renov plus 100 milliard 5 dans les
investissements verts dans le cadre de
France 2030 plus de 200 million d'euros
pour acheter une voiture propre plus de
500 millions d'euros pour le fond vert
des collectivités territoriales quel
autre groupe politique peut se targuer
d'avoir autant investi dans cet enjeu
crucial quand il était au pouvoir en
voulant censurer le gouvernement c'est
ces mesures de financement des
transitions
écologiques auquel vous vous opposez
trème investissement majeur le soutien
au pouvoir d'achat notre pôle régalien
et nos politiques publiques prioritair
le pouvoir d'achat des Français c'est
notre priorité indexation du barê de
l'impôt sur le revenu et de la prime
d'activation d'activité sur l'inflation
revalorisation des retraites des
prestations sociales et du point analyse
de la fonction publique dans ce texte
nous y répondons en voulant censurer le
gouvernement chers collègues c'est à ces
mesures de soutien au pouvoir d'achat
que vous vous opposez le budget 2024
c'est aussi 47 milliards de dépenses
pour la défense plus 3,3 milliards en
2024 qui voudrait aujourd'hui désarmer
notre pays 11 milliards pour la justice
plus de 10000 personnes personnel d'ici
2027 qui peut dire que nous pourrions
nous en passer 16,5 milliards pour la
sécurité qui aujourd'hui peut-être
contre
ensuite bien sûr l'éducation plus de 63
milliards à quoi serviront-ils d'abord à
revaloriser dignement nos enseignants à
renforcer
notre contingent d'accompagnant de nos
élèves en situation de handicap ou
encore à financer la réforme du lycée
professionnel et agricole enfin j'y
tiens tout particulièrement le soutien
de de notre agriculture nous y
consacrons 7 milliards d'euros qui
permettront d'accompagner nos
agriculteurs dans leur transition
écologique de soutien la consommation de
produits bio de renforcer l'innovation
dans le secteur agricole ou encore
d'aider nos forêts face aux aléas en
voulant censurer le gouvernement c'est à
ces mesures d'investissement dans nos
politiques publiques que vous vous
opposez ce budget s'inscrit ainsi dans
la volonté de notre majorité et du
gouvernement d'une plus grande justice
fiscale d'abord ord en luttant plus
efficacement contre la fraude le PLF met
en œuvre le volet fiscal de notre
feuille de route antifraude afin de
mieux repérer et condamner ceux qui
fraudent nos finances publiques la
justice fiscale s'illustre aussi dans la
création d'un niveau minimum
d'imposition à l'ensemble des grandes
entreprises et de leur filial au niveau
mondial cette mesure issue de la
directive sur le pilier 2 de le CDE
permettra 1,5 milliards d'euros de
recettes supplémentaires en 2026 vous
l'aviez rêver vous en auriez rêvé il y a
quelques années c'est notre majorité qui
le met en place en voulant censurer le
gouvernement c'est à toutes ces mesur de
justice fiscale que vous vous opposez
enfin en voulant censurer le
gouvernement c'est un budget de soutien
nos collectivités territorial que vous
vous opposez
également nous augmentons de 320
millions d'euros la DGF donnons au
département les moyens de palier à la
baisse de leur DMTO nous aidons les
collectivités à renforcer leurs
investissements verts nous soutenons les
communes nouvelles nous augmentations
les dotations pour les élus locaux ce
soutien en collectivité territoriale est
particulièrement important mais il ne
doit pas les exonérer de participer
activement au redressement de nos
comptes publics et de la transition
écologique un texte crucial donc qui a
aussi été enrichi de nos travaux chers
collègues avec près de 500 amendements
qui ont été retenus dans la copie finale
pour la justice fiscale pour nos
collectivités territoriales pour la
culture pour la transition écologique
pour les Françaises et pour les Français
je voudrais remercier l'ensemble des
groupes qui ont participé à cette
coconstruction sur l' sur l'Que
République avant de conclure je voudrais
encore remercier comme l'ont fait un
certain nombre de mes collègues
l'ensemble des administrateurs de
l'Assemblée nationale qui ont travaillé
jour et nuit afin que notre débat puisse
avoir lieu merci également à l'ensemble
de nos collaborateurs par
parlementairire pour leur travail chers
collègues voter une motion de censure
sur le budget c'est vuvré en faveur du
chaos les Français nous ont élu pour
agir pas pour bloquer notre Parlement
pas pour le bruit et la fureur mais pour
le dialogue et l'action pas pour
paréaliser le pays mais pour le faire
avancer j'appelle de mes vœux que le
prochain budget puisse faire l'objet
d'une large coconstruction entre les
groupes parlementaires ma porte restera
toujours ouvert pour celles et ceux qui
veulent travailler ensemble sur un
budget au service des Françaises et des
Français le groupe Renaissance
renouvelle sa confiance au gouvernement
d'Élisabeth Bor et ne votera donc
naturellement pas cette notion de so de
censure joyeux à tous et très bonne fête
de fin d'année merci merci Monsieur
rapporteur
général et enfin la parole est à Madame
Lisette poet pour le groupe
rassemblement
national
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues on peut faire
1 49 3 mais pas 15 on peut faire 2 49 3
mais pas 15 vous ce n'est pas 15 mais
bien 23 493 que vous faites c'est la 23
23e fois que vous avez dégainé le
revolver antidémocratique du 493 une
nouvelle fois l'hémicycle est quasiment
vide et vous n et nous nous retrouvons à
commenter une énième motion de censure
déposé par l'extrême gauche en réponse à
nm 493 imposé par le gouvernement ils
sont le symbole évident du refus du
gouvernement à discuter à chercher des
compromis mais vous ne pourrez pas tenir
4 ans comme cela vous voilà destent trce
d'un record bien tristement célèbre
personne n'avait autant méprisé les
représentants du peuple vous l'avez
déclenché avant même que que ne débute
le débat et la discussion générale sur
la der la dernière lecture du texte ce
n'est pas neutre vous n'avez même pas
voulu écouter une seule seconde les
arguments des groupes politiques qui
composent l'assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée du peuple les débats du PLF
2024 se compte sur les doigts d'une main
n'ayant pas la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale Michel Rocard a eu recours 28
fois l'article 493 de la Constitution
pour 13 textes ce qui fait de lui le
chef du gouvernement ayant le plus
souvent utilisé cette procédure vous y
êtes presque madame la ministre première
ministre excusez-moi un petit effort et
le record sera pour
vous autoritarisme et mépris du
Parlement de mots qui qui définissent
votre vision vous imposez un budget dont
les Français ne veulent pas l'objectif
est donc atteint pour vous le 493
devient un usage plus personne ne
s'étonne de cette stratégie
gouvernementale vous serit connu madame
born pour vos 493 à répétition et votre
mépris de la démocratie et pourtant nous
refusons de nous habituer à ces salves
de 493 l'usage abusif de cet outil
constitutionnel ne vous permettra pas
une majorité dans cette hémicycle en
plus d'être méprisante envers la
démocratie représentative vous avez tout
comme l'an dernier profité des 493 pour
retirer des amendements adoptés en
commission ou au contraire ajouter des
dispositions qui n'ont pas été discuté
par le Parlement vous avez fait votre
petit trou votre petit tri votre
tambouille à la sauce gouvernementale
qui laisse un goût un mer au français
mais parlons de budget puisque nous
sommes ici la première ministre ayant
engagé la responsabilité du Gouvernement
sur l'adoption en en lecture définitive
du projet de loi de finances pour 2024
votre bilan est désastreux les impôts
des des Français augmentent deux fois
plus que l'inflation quatre fois plus
que la croissance selon le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques le budget 2024
repose sur des prévisions de croissance
et d'inflation irréaliste les dépenses
continueront à progresser si
sensiblement en 2024 le ratio de la
dette publique après avoir baissé en
2024 grâce à une croissance inhabituelle
forte du PIB en valeur ne se réduirait
pas en 2024 ainsi la France qui a vu sa
position d'endettement relatif au sein
de la zone euro se dégrader au cours des
dernières années conserverai en 2024 un
niveau d'endettement élevé tous les pays
de l'Union européenne auront un déficit
public inférieur à 3 % du PIB d'ici 2025
tous sauf le nôtre qui sera le dernier à
repasser sous la barre des 3 %. déjà à
bissal la dette qui dépasse 3000
milliards d'euros continuera donc à
augmenter en empruntant plus de 285
milliards d'euros en 2024 un montant
encore jamais atteint la France sera le
trè pays le plus endetté d'Europe
derrière l'Italie et la Grèce vos belles
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui y
croient et les Français ont bien compris
qu'avec vous leur vie ne peut
s'améliorer réellement même l'indemnité
carburant qui devait les aider n'est pas
suffisante et ne sera accordée que si
les prix des carburants atteignent 2 €
le litre selon Bruno Le Maire et c'est
précisément pour cela qu'ils vous ont
mis en minorité lors des dernières
élections législatives ils nous ont élus
pour contrôler ce gouvernement ils nous
ont élu pour un renouveau démocratique
les Français se demandent s'ils pourront
encore chauffer se chauffer nourrir
leurs enfants ou ou leur offrir quelques
cadeaux pour Noël les Français ne
peuvent plus se soigner au moment où
l'hôpital craque de partout où nous
aurions besoin de de solutions pérenne
afin de sauver un système de santé qui
voilà quelques années encore était la
fierté de notre pays et la référence du
monde entier les Français jour après
jour ne vous font plus confiance et
rejettent la politique menée par
Emmanuel Macron et son gouvernement vous
vous vous osez dire que vous engagez la
responsabilité du gouvernement du fait
qu'aucun groupe d'opposition ne souhait
travailler avec vous pour bâtir un un
budget mais cela est faux Marine Le Pen
et les députés du premier groupe
d'opposition vous ont fait des
propositions sur l'école nos amendements
visant à favoriser les acquis
fondamentaux et le retour de la
discipline uniforme scolaire
apprentissage des langues RAR ou encore
enseignement du français n'ont pas
manqué nous avons également formulé des
propositions sur l'agriculture visant au
renouvellement générationnel des
agriculteurs sur la question de
l'handicap tendant à la revalorisation
de laallocation aux handicapés au-dessus
du seuil de provoté sur l'énergie visant
au développement des technologies
d'avenir telles que l'hydrogène nous
vous proposons de baisser la TVA de 20 à
55 sur les produits énergétiques
carburant fu gaz électricité en tant que
bien de première nécessité cette mesure
pérenne permettra de rendre
immédiatement du pouvoir d'achat au
ménages les plus modestes et aux classes
moyennes nous allons encore plus loin en
proposant d'appliquer une TVA 0 % au
lieu de 55 sur un panier de 100 produits
alimentaires et d'hygiène de première
nécessité et cela fonctionne nos voisins
du Portugal l'ont fait et les prix ont
baissé les Portugais sont contents de ce
dispositif et les mesures sont
reconduites la Banque centrale du
Portugal vient de démontrer que cette
solution de Marine Le Pen avait
fonctionné contrairement à votre prop e
pour continuer à ponctionner les
Français le pouvoir d'achat est
incontestable incontestablement la
préoccupation du moment pour tout le
monde c'est encore plus vrai pour les
plus modestes car les prix du quotidien
augmentent plus rapidement nous nous
nous proposons des solutions pour
soulager les Français et répondre à
leurs attentes c'est pour cela que nous
avons voté le projet de loi immigration
qui bien que largement largement
insuffisant est une première pierre
àorttere à l'édifice pour la sécurité
des Français vous êtes sur le bon chemin
allez encore plus loin et donner la
parole aux Français par un référendum
nous proposons également de privatiser
partiellement l'audiovisuel soit 2,5
milliards d'économie vous vous ajouter
une taxe trè MIM qui quoi que vous
disiez se traduira probablement par une
hausse des prix donc une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat pour les classes
moyennes une fois une nouvelle fois
cette décision devrait indirectement
faire le jeu des gafas au détriment des
plus petite plateforme qui peineent à
être rentable les calculs ne sont pas
bons madame la Première ministre puisque
certaines ont même annoncé des investir
la France madame la Première ministre à
côté de cela vous faites un cadeau
fiscal inacceptable aux fédérations
sportives internationale cet amendement
FIFA pour ne pas le nommer prévoit le
rétablissement d'une exonération de
l'impôt sur les société de cotisation
foncière des entreprises et de
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises pour pour leur mission de
gouvernance du sport ou de promotion de
la pratique du sport ces fédérations
vous remercient pour ce mini paradis
fiscal vous vous vous plaignez du manque
de budget de l'État mais l'argent existe
mettez un terme à la fraude fiscale
stoppez les agissements de ceux qui
abusent de notre système de santé il y a
un moyen qui permettrait pourtant de
récupérer 1,2 milliard d'euros par an
mais il faut de la volonté pour la
mettre en place récupérer les fonds
engloutis au titre de l'aide médicale
d'État pour soigner gratuitement des
immigrés clandestins mieux traités dans
notre pays que des milliux que des
millions de Français qui eux côtisent
pourtant la sécurité sociale et qui
doivent choisir entre se nourrir et se
soigner en définitive le le budget
retenu dans la version finale du texte
ne tient pas compte de la majorité des
observations votées vous n'en avez cure
et vous vous asseyez sur le travail des
parlementaires nous déplorons l'absence
de solutions pertinentes adaptées
durable et donc efficace au crise dont
les Français sont victimes vous êtes
déconnecté madame la Première ministre
et votre budget est hors sol il ne
correspond pas aux besoins cruciaux et
au réalité des territoires votre vision
s'il y en a une n'est pas à long terme
vous gérez péniblement à la petite
semaine le budget de la France le projet
de loi de finances que vous imposez est
déficitaire comme chaque année
malheureusement depuis 50 ans la seule
charge de la dette de la dette coûtera
aux Français 61 milliards d'euros en
2024 plus que par par exemple le budget
des armées ou celui de la sécurité qui
sont pourtant au premier rang des
priorités en 2024 vous allez continuer
de creuser la dette de la France et
c'est sans compter l'abération d'indexer
la dette sur l'inflation ce qui nous
coûte plusieurs milliards par l' par an
excusez-moi mais jusqu'où irez-vous
combien de temps allez-vous encore
gouverner sans la représentation
nationale c'est-à-dire gouvern sans les
Français les motions de censure N non
plus aucun sens pour vous chers
collègues d'extrême gauche elles
deviennent inutile et inoffensive à
aucun moment en effet vous ne cherchez à
rendre un réel service au français vous
tombez dans le piège du gouvernement
déposer une motion de censure à chaque
493 ne nous fera pas avancer le
gouvernement n'en AFF faire que nen a à
faire que des des oppositions de leurs
propositions pensez-vous réellement
qu'elle puisse aboutir un jeudi 21
décembre alors que la plupart des
députés seront partis en en
circonscription
vous vous illustrez bien ces propos de
sireno de Bergerac mais on se bat pas
pour les dans lesport du succès non non
c'est bien plus beau c'est donc inutile
en déposant systématiquement une motion
de réjet préalable sur chaque texte et
une motion de censure après chaque 493
vous décrédibiliseer dévaloriseres ces
outils politiques vous ne pouvez pas
vous plaindre du manque de débat et de
censure à bout de champ même si nous
sommes pas en accord avec ce projet de
loi de finances nous ne voterons pas en
faveur de cette éè motion de censure qui
une fois ne servira à rien mais vous
nous trouverez vend debout dès qu'un
projet de loi menacera le pouvoir
d'achat la sécurité l'identité de nos
compatriotes les Français attendent un
un budget responsable les français
demandent un budget responsable qui
améliore leur qualité de vie et ce que
et c'est ce que nous leur donnerons avec
Marine Le Pen la seule solution pour un
changement concret et le respect de la
démocratie j'en profite pour vous
souhaiter à tous un joyeux Noël et de
bonnes
fête merci Madame Polet chaque orateur
de groupe s'étant exprimé la parole est
à madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et mieurs les
députés avant toute chose je veux
exprimer mon émotion après la fusillade
meurtrière si vous vouliez bien écouter
y compris sur les bancs de
LFI avant toute chose je veux exprimer
mon émotion après la fusillade
meurtrière qui a durement frappé le
peuple tchque à
Prague j'ai changé tout à l'heure avec
le président PAV je lui exprime à titre
personnel au nom de de mon gouvernement
et je n'en doute pas en notre nom à tous
mon soutien et ma
[Applaudissements]
solidarité pour venir à l'objet de notre
séance alors que je vous retrouve cette
après-midi pour répondre à la 31e motion
de censure déposée contre mon gouver
la dernière de cet exercice
budgétaire je crois que lors du bilan
l'ORS d'un bilan du recours frénétiique
aux motions de censure est
venue avec 31 motions de censure soit
plus d'un cè des motions déposé sous la
5e République en un an et demi qu'on
réussi les députés
sensur d'abord ils ont réussi à
dénaturer le principe d'émotion de
censure chacun le
chacun le sait nous avons respecté
l'esprit et la lettre de la
Constitution depuis septembre nous avons
déposé des
493 sur trois textes des textes
financiers nous l'avons fait pour la
simple raison que nous avons besoin d'un
budget et qu'aucun groupe d'opposition
ne souhaite le construire avec
nous ce sont des faits des fait quene
ici n'a jamais
contesté à 31 reprises discours après
discours les partisans de la censure ont
revendiqué fièrement leur refus de
dialogue et aucun d'eux n'a donné l'once
du début d'une explication sur la
manière dont le gouvernement pouvait
trouver une majorité sur un budget dans
ces
conditions pouvoir continuer à gouverner
le pays même en l'absence de majorité
c'est le sens même donn les auteurs de
la Constitution à l'article
493 c'est précisément ce que nous
faisons la situation est donc très
simple et nos concitoyens le savent bien
il y a vous qui voulez bloquer le pays
et nous qui voulons agir pour les
Français de votre côté vous n'hésitez
pas à tordre le bras des dispositions
constitutionnelles les motions de
censure sont censé être réservées pour
des moments
exceptionnels lors de la précédente
législature en majorité
relative lors de la précédente lors de
la précédente législature en majorité
relative de 1988 à
1993 39 493 avait conduit à seulement H8
motions de
censure sans doute à l'époque les
oppositions é-elle plus respectueuse des
usages assurément elle respectait
davantage nos
institutions visiblement elles avaient
conscience que les motion de censure
déposé par réflexe les videraient de
leur sens et de leur portée elles
avaient aussi conscience que dans des
délais constitutionnels contraints pour
l'examen des textes financiers la
systématisation des motions de censure
et le temps nécessaire pour les examiner
ne laisse aucun espace pour un débat sur
le fond des
textes le deuxième point au bilan des
députés senseur c'est d'avoir prouvé
qu'il n'avait pas de majorité
alternative à 30 reprises déjà vous avez
tenté de faire tomber le gouvernement à
30 reprises vous avez échoué si vous
vouliez démontrer haut et fort que vous
aviez perdu les élections
présidentielles et législative et qu'il
n'existait aucune autre majorité capable
de gouverner vous n'aviez pas de
meilleur
chemin alors merci à tous les députés
senseurs de la nupè ou du rassemblement
national d'avoir à 30 reprises permis de
conforter mon gouvernement devant cette
assemblée
la troisième chose que vous avez
démontré lors de ces motions de censure
à répétition c'est celle de l'alliance
de fêes entre la nupesse et l'extrême
[Applaudissements]
droite s'il vous
plaît merci Monsieur Lucas
merci s'il vous plaît pendant vous s'il
vous plaît pendant vos interventions
j'ai tout entendu alors je ne vais pas
alimenter des polémiques moi je me
contente des faits les faits les faet
c'est que la nupes a multiplié les
appels du pied au rassemblement
national je vous
rappelle je vous
rappelle s'il vous plaît madame Rousseau
je vous
remercie madame Rousseau merci se la
première ministre la parole s'il vous
plaît madame rousseauadame Rousseau je
vous rappelle chacun retrouve son calme
je vous rappelle que c'est le leader de
la France insoumise lui-même qui vous
avait donné des règles pour une motion
de censure acceptable et votable par
l'extrême droite nous nous assumons de
la combattre frontalement nous assumons
de vouloir répondre aux inquiétudes sur
lesquelles ell
prospère
madame Rousseau s'il vous plaît l'effet
c'est que la nupes cherche les votes du
rassemblement national et les accepte
allègrement motion après motion s'il
vous
plaît merci nous les voix du
rassemblement national nous les refusons
nous les écartons nous ne les comptons
pas
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît et vous le démontrez une fois
de plus c'est que l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite déploie les mêmes
techniques les invectifs plutôt que les
idées les outrance plutôt que la vérité
les hurlements plutôt que les
débats toutes les opinions contraires au
vôtres vous gênent vous préférez les
couvrir d'injure plutôt que de les
écouter extrême gauche et extrême droite
ce sont les mêmes méthodes le même refus
du
pluralisme alors vos
justifi alors vos justifications capilot
tracté n'y feront rien sur ces bans
chacun en est témoins laanupess et le
rassemblement national ne cessent de se
ménager et de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'allier un peu de calme oh s'il vous
plaît un peu de
calme merci merci chers collègues
monsieur Lucas s'il vous plaît merci
Madame enfin
[Musique]
enfin enfin le dernier enseignement de
cette série de
motion enfin le dernier enseignement de
motion s'il vous plaît c'est que les
députés monsieur GED bon merci que c'est
que les députés senseurs ont tenté avec
constance de bloquer des progrès et des
investissements majeurs au service de
nos concitoyens vous voulez censurer la
création de 2300 postes de policiers et
de gendarmes l'année prochaine une
augmentation du budget du ministère de
la Justice de moitié par rapport à 2017
une hausse sans précédent des moyens de
nos armé vous voulez censurer un budget
vert 40 milliards d'euros
d'investissement pour la transition
écologique c'est 7 milliards d'euros de
plus que l'année dernière c'est inédit
vous voulez censurer un budget
historique pour notre école avec une
augmentation de salaire de 125 € par
mois au minimum pour nos enseignants
avec des moyens renforcés pour la lutte
contre le harcèlement
scolaire vous voulez censureer des
mesures pour venir en aide au plus
fragiles et pour lutter contre les
inégalités des investissements
supplémentaires pour lutter contre la
pauvreté des ement pour une campagne de
testing contre les
discriminations vous voulez censurer la
création d'une aide universelle
d'urgence pour les victimes de violence
conjugale vous voulez censurer une
hausse de la DGF pour nos communes
censurer des moyens supplémentaires pour
nos outrè des moyens attendus pour les
infrastructures du quotidien pour
rénover les réseau d'eau pour l'accès à
l'emploi les femmes les enseignants les
élus locaux citoyen ultramarins vous
prétendez les défendre vous voulez
censurer leurs
moyens et en guide de programme
budgétaire que proposez-vous aux
Français vous voulez les écraser d'impôt
nous nous les augmentons pas vous voulez
faire exploser la dette et mettre en
danger notre souveraineté nous nous
réduisons les déficits
publicsames et Messieurs les Députés la
censure c'est bloquer le pays c'est
priver les Français des moyens dont ils
ont besoin des moyens qu'ils attendent
avec mon gouvernement avec la majorité
nous ne laisserons pas faire nous ne
laisserons jamais faire et toujours nous
continuerons à agir pour les Français je
vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre la discussion est close je vais
maintenant mettre au voix la motion de
censure le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale je
rappelle que seul les députés favorables
à la motion de censure participent au
scrutin et que le vote se déroule dans
les salles voisines de l'hémicycle le
scrutin va donc être ouvert pour 20
minutes il sera clos à
17h33 la séance est
suspendue la séance est
reprise voici les résultats du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres de cette Assemblée
289 pour l'adoption 116 la majorité
requise n'étant pas atteinte la motion
de censure n'est pas adopté en
conséquence le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 est considéré comme adopté en
lecture définitive